سنوات عجاف بلغ عدد اثنتي عشره سنه رفرف
خلالها العلم السوري واحدا ثم جاءت السنه
التي اغيثت فيه العلاقات السوريه العربيه
ليتوسط العلم السوري اعلام باقي الدول
المشكله للمنظمه من جديد الموعد قمه جده
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان رحب بمشاركه الوفد السوري في دوره
القمه العربيه الثانيه والثلاثين
وانتهز هذه الفرصه للترحيب بمشاركه
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في اجتماعنا
اليوم
ترحيب كبير من دمشق بالعوده للحضن العربي
السعوديه بدلت جهد هائل من اجل تحسين
الاجواء العربيه ومن اجل
احتضان جميع الدول العربيه ونحن ممتنون ان
كل الدول العربيه الان موجوده في هذه
القمه المقعد لم يعد شاغرا وسوريا ابرز
الحاضرين
ترحب الجزائر ايام ترحيب
ببوادر تكريس هذا التوجه
الذي بدات تتجلى
ملامحه مع استئناف الجمهوريه العربيه
السوريه الشقيقه شغله مقعدها بمنظمتنا
عوده تنظر منها الجامعه تفاعلا سوريا بناء
وايجابيا وفق ما جاء على لسان الامين
العام احمد ابو الغيط واتمنى ان تكون
استعادت سوريا لمقعدها مقدمه لانهاء
ازمتها
والاستعادتها لحيويتها وحضورها في العمل
العربي عوده سوريا الى حضنها العربي اهم
حدث قبل انعقاد القمه قمه ينظر اليها
مراقبون باعتبارها فرصه لمناقشه ابرز
القضايا التي تهم المنطقه العربيه بلال
البجدين العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات